[Music]
foreign
stands away
[Music]
tried to cross at the quiet Edge
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
is
this round is
[Music]
I know we let go of these ghosts
hey friends I hope you enjoyed that
thanks to the wonderful Mufasa for doing
the camera work there uh fun fact he's
the one that made up the path that we
followed there uh first time in the
director's chair so thank you so much
Mufasa of course it was all according to
plan
uh where can people find you on social
media mate y'all can find me at Fuego
monster on YouTube Instagram and
Facebook that's Marissa Instagram these
days wicked cool well thank you again so
much for your help of course well cool
until next time see you back inside hey
y'all wasn't that a cool spot that is uh
Pershing Park it is right next to a spot
called Freedom Plaza that's about a
block away from the White House ran
across that randomly one day while I was
on a walk and was just like I like this
and I want to spin here so um big thanks
go out to flow toys for sponsoring this
video and making it possible for me to
do an awesome flow session out there
um real quickly uh you can get a set of
those uh FPC pod poi that is plug play
with FPC tethers by using the promo code
drexfactor 2023 over at checkout over at
flowtoys.com and that is a zero instead
of an o in Drex Factor use that code to
check out and it gets you a discount on
your own set of those POI or any POI in
the shop and even better than that it
helps out the channel so go check that
out thank you so much to flowtoys for
sponsoring this video speaking of thank
yous
big thanks go to the Friends of the
channel big thanks too uh dark monk uh
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for making the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business friend of the
channel That is Becca becklenen thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission finally
this video would not be possible we're
not for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you so much one and all for your
very generous support and if you out
there watching are not currently a
supporter but you'd like to become one
you can do that by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome Rewards words but even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring POI spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world go
check that out please and thank you if
you'd like to check out some more of my
awesome flow videos I will go ahead and
include a link to a playlist of them
down in the description as well as up
here on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also if you are watching on
YouTube the YouTube algorithm thinks
that you'll really like this top video
here based upon your past viewing habits
so maybe give that a look as well thank
you so much for watching please make
sure to like And subscribe and I will
see you with a new video real soon also
make sure to get out and flow today see
you later peace